Here's how the site works at the moment.
When you navigate to Witter, the browser
makes a request for some HTML.
Like all web requests,
this goes via the browser's HTTP cache.
And if there's no match there,
it continues on to the internet.
Then hopefully, the response makes
its way back to the browser.
The html the browser receives tells it
it needs some CSS, so that's fetched.
Once that arrives, we get our first
render, a page full of content.
You see the initial set of posts
are right there in the HTML.
But at the same time
the browser downloaded the CSS,
it's also requesting some JavaScript.
And when that arrives it opens
a websocket, a persistent connection
that let's the server continually
stream newer posts as they arrive.
This provides the live updates so
the user doesn't miss out on
a single piece of nonsense
posted by the other users.
In terms of the pages JavaScript
you'll find that in public JS main.
The starting point is index.js,
but all this does is load,
polyfill is that some browsers
may need such as promises and
the URL API which will use
a little bit later on.
The main work happens
in IndexController.js.
The constructor here is run for
every page load.
We have this PostsView which helps
us update the post on the page.
This ToastsView helps us
display error messages,
hopefully we won't get
too many of those.
And then we open a socket connection.
The open socket method, well as you
might guess opens the WebSocket and
the message event is fired when data
is received for a new post to display.
When you post a received
on socket messages called,
this method passes the data is chosen
and passes the result to the PostView.
While the server is running,
any changes you make to these
files will be processed and built.
I didn't want ES6 to be
a prerequisite for this course, so
i'm going to stick to ES5.
But the build system uses babel so if
you're like a cool kid from the future.
Feel free to use some of
the latest JavaScript syntax.
And i almost forgot.
There's actually another server
running on port 8889 so open up.
This gives you basic control over
your connectivity to the server.
How to play with the settings.
Refresh the page and
see how it responds.
You'll see things are pretty bad
in everything except perfect mode.
Over the course of this course, we're
going to fix the non perfect cases.